I actually have a challenge for you
before the game starts are you ready
mm-hmm
can you say pons eonni six times fast
pons eonni pons eonni Ponciano kanjyani
Ponciano ponds eonni go check hard there
you go
fine you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
up the difficulty for your next
challenge
we do have the game on on the board okay
so II four is played by Ludwig five okay
as expected
welcome taking a deep breath okay
nine up three and yeah chad is saying
that challenge was hard for a human no
don't worry guys this was part of
keycards last patch now if Ludwig is
gonna play that what I suggest yes now
we're gonna see just did box box go back
and watch the vote or not we're gonna
see the psychology here the box box if
he watched the vibe if you watch the
vaad what do you expect from him here he
would move quickly okay he did not watch
the vaad because he played jeez that's
right away there would there are more
much more aggressive replies in the
center of the board that you should play
here so okay this is actually quite good
for for Ludwig if he should push the
pawn following the principles push the
pawn in the center and then bring out
the bishop right away to c4 and he did
it so he is using the notes from his
lesson and sooner we're gonna see him
develop his bishop as he saw it along
right and yeah and so basically here you
take with the pawn and that the key is
that is that white gets the center very
quickly here you can push the pawns you
can attack the knight I will say however
that I did not actually show this Jesus
move to to ludwig cuz it's a move that
is slightly inferior it's not the best
move in the position so I this is very
critical already for box box very
important here that he plays Bishop to
g7 if he plays any other move here he
could end up in a lot of trouble right
away so this is this is this is very
critical and we're only what four moves
into the game so it's gonna be I think
that's gonna be one of the games which
is very tense at from the very beginning
and
I think he's listening to classical
music and he has a very funny comment he
said can't be copy struck if the guy
died 300 years ago one of my many five
had moves I'll be making today nice so
okay so you should take the pawn and
bring the knight into the center of the
board this is why I think it's very
risky what's happening at the start of
this game by box box because if one wood
takes the pawn and then brings the
knight to attack the Queen he is already
much much better in this game right but
I wonder how intuitive that is for him
because I think a move that might come
more naturally to little he's just to
take out his knight kind of you know
just adhering to those basic opening
principles to try to develop your pieces
quickly right right that that is a
reasonable way of playing it I think I
did tell him though that he does if your
opponent moves the Queen out early it's
not it's it's violating the principles
so I do I do see a way that he could
rationalize taking the pawn here even if
it's not the most obvious move yeah that
makes sense
so I'm loading up his stream to see if
we can get some of his thoughts here as
well it's still loading I need to
subscribe so that I you know don't get
these ads but it'll happen and box box
so he has nine minutes say 25 bucks
right so so what was the thing about
moving the bishop I I'm actually
listening in got it alright so he moved
the bishop and this wasn't the most
accurate move the pawn on e4 unguarded
yeah but it's very weird position
because after black takes the pawn you
can move the knight to e5 and it's still
very unclear sorry I just meant to say
that we did at Ludwig and he is alive so
we can hear his thoughts or actually his
500 year-old music expected
so he said he expected this do you think
he's gonna move his Knight to e5 I think
it's critical that he does it's a bad
exchange yeah I could battery I actually
don't feel too bad about battery here
this is actually kind of a bait I wonder
if he takes us baiting box box if he
takes my knight on f3 he's alright
then I take Knight C so I can only
respond let's go back to the game horn
then I take his I think we're gonna go
back to the mute so that we can you know
explain what's going on in the game
right right so he has he's trying to
remember what I showed him the yet last
night the problem is here o box box
doesn't take the night oh no no no no no
I mean he still has a good position but
he's completely winning yeah if he took
the night he was just winning also be
kind of worked I guess by Ludwig he
still us to move the knight on this move
though yes I moved the knight here
he's gotta move the knight so he doesn't
lose the knight for free yeah and he
seems surprised by this he thought I'm
worried that he's gonna leave the knight
there cuz he thinks it's still good bait
I don't think so because again one of
the things I said is if you look at the
ratings Ludwig is 1,100 so loved ones
rating actually is pretty high amongst
amongst most of players so I don't think
he's gonna leave it hanging for a second
time here I expect him to move the
knight there you go
did 95 great move on his end box box has
to be a little bit careful to not make
any mistakes here but he can go for just
a night trade yeah but this is actually
I think completely okay for white
because if you trade the Knights and the
bishops then you're gonna lose a pawn on
this b7 square so yeah this is this game
is still very very unclear and and it's
the first game I think we've seen where
the players have gotten into a position
very early on where neither player knows
knows knows what they're doing like they
don't have a set plan or set strategy
and I think in all the other games we've
seen the players get out the opening
phase relatively quickly without any
trouble and this game both players are
kind of up and down it's very very
imbalanced I don't really know what's
gonna happen
and let's say they trade off into a
middle game or an end game then that's
where box box would be the favorite but
let me get probably not thinking like
that I feel like
he's confident yeah I think what what
generally is is very confident he
believes in himself and he's got a good
position here I think this is this is
very very good for him at this point I
really do like like what he's done so
far even if the even if pure dream
wasn't quite right yeah fair enough
so box boxes is taking a think here
maybe we can go and listen to what he's
saying here I love the animation he has
on his board okay we're we're about to
pull up his dream I'll take now at which
point I'll take you now no that's not
good for me that's not good for me
mm-hmm
I'm actually really nervous I'm really
scared here do I have to go here I feel
like I have to okay so then what happens
after he does this
am I then taking a night I like the way
he's thinking through this the only
problem is that you yeah I think at that
point I'm taking night have quite a bit
of a time sink yeah I mean I think I
think for box box this is yeah this is
Jerry tricky and I think you might want
to show are you showing screen or not oh
yeah 8700 will get will get I think I
thought we were on his screen oh no we
were just listening to him sorry I
thought we had his arrows on the board
that was my bad 97 what are your
thoughts here I mean I think it's it's
probably the best move but it's also a
very risky move because white can now
bring the bishop out to it to pin the
knight and the Queen okay this is also
reasonable and just shout out to
everybody 60,000 people this is
currently the most watched show on
twitch right now and you guys were here
a hikaru Ludwig Bach socks huge shout
out thanks so much everyone this is this
is exciting I this is this is definitely
the premiere game of the first set of
matches and so far it's living up to the
billing
even if there was this big hiccup where
a black could have taken the night so so
yeah I think I think so far this is a
very good opening for Ludwig's not doing
badly Albert actually box box he looks a
little bit uncomfortable normally what
I've watched him do his dreams and he's
he's explaining his moves he he doesn't
look uncomfortable and he actually looks
a little bit uncomfortable right now
just looking at the physical body
language so I I think this is anyone's
game right and I mean at some point if
lytic wants to take advantage she is
gonna have to trade off and it seems
like that moment is now since box box is
putting pressure on his knight on e5 so
he probably anticipates the threat as
well yeah I think probably what he
should do is you should probably take
the bishop of the night and then develop
his night play for the quick attack
rather than something slow this is one
thing I tried to sort of explain to him
last night when I was helped me out is
play play aggressively don't don't sort
of sit back and let the let your
opponent kind of out play or outmaneuver
out strategize you because the
difference between the players of these
level
is basically the only chance you're
gonna have to beat them as if you can if
you can make them uncomfortable and get
them to make a blunder in the opening
phase the game and [__] about four by
the way which was played is also a very
good move I do like this so Bishop f4
and box box now pushes a six so he is I
I did like 97-year idea made a lot of
sense to get the bishop pair off but he
developed so that's intuitive his oh
well yeah the problem is that Knight
takes e5 is gonna get rid of the threat
on f7 and also attack the Queen at the
same time so if box box sees this he is
winning I think I think he ki Carr who
had a heart attack no I'm still here
like yeah okay why has the box box
taking the knight right away well why
don't we actually take a look at box box
now if we can just do that quickly so we
can see what he's saying no it's gonna
play b5 oh he castled okay he didn't go
for it go for it oh no okay but he's no
battery so it's a tough position there's
a lot going on I understand why he's
afraid about that so I just want to say
that for box box it is a tough position
he's still better and I know for Ludwig
also it's hard to see ologies there's so
much try right now obviously I'm defense
alright there's exactly too much going
on complicated and also the other thing
is look at the time like they're both
very low on time and we're only what
like I move like move Newtown or
something yeah like both players have
already used half their time and we're
so early on I think this is this is very
very messy and I do worry for box box
because he's already miss
makes me feel like--that's that's God's
looking down on me as I made such a high
level of understanding I love it yeah I
mean I mean I guess the way I would say
is like when I look at these games there
are certain people were based on what
I've seen out of them I do expect them
to see certain basic concepts or
tactical ideas so that's the reason that
I am somewhat disappointed because I
have seen box box play some really good
chess and he's definitely capable of
seeing these these ideas yeah absolutely
and so here it seems like he's very
worried about that pawn on f7 and he can
just eliminate the threat by getting rid
of the knight on e5 because then if
Bishop takes rook takes and it's
defended pawn is offended twice as
attack three three times so if you get
rid of one of those attackers he should
be comfortable and he's managed to
develop and get to safety here yeah I'm
I mean I don't know what to make the
play it's like it feels like Ludwig
makes a blunder every other move and
then the other movie plays is always
very very good like Queen b3 is an
excellent move here by Ludwig because
you don't you don't want to move your
night and help activate the black bishop
so I'm this games just been very
confusing because Ludwig plays a blunder
and then he plays it like a great move
and any place blunder and then he plays
a great move so he's either very very
very up and down but right now he's on
the right temple he's out coming off the
good move so ono Bishop e6 oh no yeah
this is pretty bad i mean if box aux
gets a bishop he is sorry if fluttery
takes the bishop then he's gonna
recapture he's currently down upon but
he gets his pawn back and on top of that
okay I see that you've all eval bar
saying he's only up a pawn but he has an
attack on the King that I think is gonna
be very scary for box box yeah so
basically you trade the bishops and then
you take with the Queen and then you
move the knight with the fork all right
oh I mouse slipped trying to show your
line okay no that's not what I meant
here we go I assume this is gonna happen
yeah so chat this is all what's
happening I just wanted to put he car
was explanation on the Lord so okay so
he played one good mover we're gonna see
two good moves it's a real question
because we saw a good move blunder good
move blunder powder from Ludwig so it's
important that Ludwig trades trades the
bishops here and just takes upon whether
you can play the sequence of the good
moves is what we're gonna see here but
if he doesn't think the one I think he
should see it he should see it let's go
to load way because I think he's about
to explain it didn't mean to cut you off
there and let's listen to what he has to
say so I could
I could bring my I come is he gonna see
it moment of truth
actually
what purpose is my bishop serving on f4
or is it better to bring a new piece out
I guess he's gonna be ending the night
yeah he's defending the night yeah hey I
can't move I can't move ah I feel I feel
like I wanted I wanted to do c3 and I
talked myself into c3 but now I'm
recognizing maybe because I didn't
activate my [__] my knight soon enough
I should just all right let's go back to
our board because we did see his move so
we'll go back to talking here Hikaru
he's keeping up the pattern
hikaru yeah I'm here okay so now box box
this is his third opportunity win the
game very important that he takes
advantage of it here this is very it's
very important also the other thing I
would say is right now both players are
getting very long the clock now both
players are down to three minutes so and
this is gonna probably be a complete
blunder fest here if box box fails to
win the game on the spot which you can I
believe with Knight takes Knight no man
if white captures Knight back you take
the bishop and the Queen and the rook
get overloaded but we'll see we'll see
if this happens I mean both players are
getting a long time both players are
clearly very nervous I think you can say
so this is I mean this is 1964 just
played okay so this is a good move
although I do worry after Queen to c3
what the next I guess you can go Knight
f3 which is probably winning but again
whether box box ceases considering how
shaky has been so far I think is uh I
mean we'll see III think he will but I
don't know if it's it's guaranteed I
mean I think this position is is very
complex for the players less than three
minutes on the time all of the pieces
are still on the board except for you
know three pawns here so there is a lot
to calculate and time pressure I think
this is going to be one of the first
games I have commentated on where time
plays a very serious role yeah I think
time will play a role here if the game
if box box needs to cease at actual
solution that wins on the next move I
think the game will end otherwise you're
right the time will definitely play a
very big role here in this game um why
don't we get out at two minutes now so
it's basically with these with these
guys I think every single move is is
super critical is basically when you
make your move then all the pressure
goes back to the other guy and so forth
with every passing move well on the
bright side for Ludwig I see him
hovering over the Queen so we're not
gonna see a blunder there right I
actually wonder if he should maybe try
to take the knight and then take the
bishop but I think considering he
already misses our community capture the
bishop right he will move the
Queen yeah cuz to play a move like rook
takes before he would have to see the
continuation otherwise it's just a bad
mood right exactly but he's having way
too long time he's got a move so what
would your advice be to players when
they're you know in complicated
positions and they're starting to take
so long on their clock
I think they should probably start
moving quicker because again I think
when you get two on the clock you're
you're you're in you're gonna end up in
a lot of trouble and hear Ludwig he
still may be okay but he's got he just
gotta make MOOCs I think once you get
too low on the clock as people who are
relatively new to chest
you're not gonna be able to see patterns
okay now I blenders now Albert has many
ways to win the game here right he has
discovery attack on f3 if he wants and
the reason why that is good is because
it opens up the Queen to take on d1 and
and this is this is a tactic that box
box would definitely see if either he
knew it was a tactic like on puzzle rush
or if he has enough time right so he
should see it I think what makes this
even easier to see is that the queen is
not attacking the knight anymore like
the Queen's not on the third-ranked
right because the Queen went down you
can also take the bishop here which is
quite good followed by Knight to eat you
Chuck okay did he move it yeah he took
that okay so now this is where if what
we can see the checkmate powder and move
his knight out to c3 there still are
some chances but I don't think he's
gonna see it and he blunders nights no I
made him to the game oh my gosh
box box art honestly that's a beautiful
finish from box box to see this
combination yeah this is a very good
finish bye-bye box box here he has that
tactical side it was a messy game we
really quite a rollercoaster to be
honest but the last blunder was on
Ludwig and box box took advantage of it
mm-hmm and box loss is gonna win the
game now Queen d1 yeah
very uh very very close game very very
tight I think until the add we weren't
sure what was gonna happen there and out
of all the games this is the one that I
think has had probably the most drama
where it wasn't clear to the deepest
moment like there's liquor an in-game of
fantastic but already someone was ahead
by his point so what a game yeah
absolutely
and we will be
Oh going on audio for box box just so we
can hear his reaction he must be pretty
happy and we actually had three wins by
black today very different than what we
usually see in traditional tournaments
okay we're about to listen to what box
box is saying it was he listening to us
oh I hope not emerge all just listening
to each other here well congratulations
box box as you are that was a fantastic
that much right now I think he's just
making sure he can open his chat I know
he put in delay and he also yeah I
understood right of course mhm and and
to explain that to chat um obviously you
know as with any games there's backseat
gaming and people can sometimes post
engine moves or higher rated players can
suggest moves so part of the rules to
make sure that doesn't happen was adding
delay to chat and also requiring players
to close our chat so you know box box
he's a good sport and nice to see that
he's being very careful with that mm-hmm
on that note we are about to go to a
quick break we're gonna show you
Ludwig's stream at the same time and
we'll be back soon with the usual
interviews yeah I'm winning slightly and
then I do the battery and I'm losing
like like like so much like so much the
correct move was Knight to e5
and then I did have an opening that I
saw but I didn't do the math on ah I was
nervous I was nervous absolutely hot for
some reason this tournament 16 people
feels like we got 12 brain-dead variety
streamers who all we do is we watch
memes and then accrue Prime subs and
then we got four whole nerds in this
tournament I don't know how they snuck
in I'll be honest okay they know who I'm
referring to I'm live on chesses stream
well good well good they should hear
this it's unfair I robbed inbox box in
the same tournament there is a
difference between the two people we can
admit this we can say it out loud
ah they want an interview do their
interview losers why do they interview
losers yeah I blundered a bunch ya
Hikaru told me not to do this but I did
it anyway yeah that copyright thing what
I have nothing i got nothing when i was
playing my 800 alone match I was I was I
was succeeding and it's weird that when
I played a 1600 Ehlo guy it wasn't
succeeding perhaps in the future I could
consider to to make him make more
blunders that would be a good plan of
action if I only had him do more
blunders I think it would have gone
differently Oh Oh perfect Oh perfect Oh
coffee on the nice sweatshirt Oh what
could go wrong that's still on the
stream why am I still on the stream what
come on show box box doing doing the
weird wheat winning kawaii wait why are
you showing this there anything else
anything at all anything just anything
all you have to do is play like play
like like head shoulders knees and toes
and they'll entertain twitchchat
play brain power this is this is a train
wreck that shouldn't be on live
television all right new plan I throw
every single match I have I get into the
consolation I beat the out of everyone
there it's a pogchamp story the whole
way through illegal how is it illegal
how is it illegal what am I supposed to
do I blunder anyway let's be real I
probably lose to Swift or check email
for interview I'm kidding
no I wouldn't do that
I respect tournaments integrities as one
of the former best super smash brothers
melee players of all times with wins
over chillindude in other names I know I
know that integrity matters
do I open am I supposed to do the
interview this box box out during the
interview are they actually interviewing
loser all right all right sure and we
are live we're joined by Ludwig and box
box light awake do you want to ask the
question you you just did before we were
on yeah Alex my questions why did you
why did you and akaru both teach me that
were clearly designed for box box to
take advantage have a better opening and
then destroy me so he Cara was talking
about how you actually had a better
opening position he carted take it away
yeah so basically in this opening box
box tried to follow what he does against
the bishop coming out right away by
playing g6 and if after pawn takes pawn
I think guys can both see the board yeah
I'm putting them on after push the pawn
in the center to this d5 square you
could have taken with pawn takes pawn
Queen takes pawn and then bring your
night out to attack the Queen and when
the Queen moves away let's just say back
to d8 here you can then push your pawn
forward to d5 and black is just way
behind there's no development and your
Bishop can come out and check the King
next move on the light squares and your
King can go out of the center and you
would have been winning so so the
question mud wig is why did you do it to
yourself okay okay there is okay so I
just learned this opening because my old
opening was literally Lopez and then and
then Hans is like Hans Thomas knock it's
an goal to and so then and so then
instead you taught me this opening
yesterday but there's so much to learn
you're supposed to battery sometimes
sometimes you're supposed to push your
pawn up sometimes you not supposed to
push up on him sometimes you're like but
you always want your pawns in the for
file ugly and these squares right here
are so important so like I'm not pushing
this up I will never push this up but
now I'm supposed to push it out but I
didn't remember that in the moment so I
went for the I was like you know I'll
just pin him I'll pin him then he can't
take me then I can't and then I have a
battery and the battery would have
worked - you actually did have chances
with the battery there - but before we
go deeper into it
box box what were your thoughts on the
opening I was
really scared I was really scared the
whole time oh ah don't fall Brady's told
I didn't realize I was making a lot of
bad moves I you don't know the end of
the game I was like I was thinking I'm
playing this pretty well but Ludwig is
playing this even better after the game
I found it we just both suck but in the
moment I was like oh my god this is
insane one wrong move and I get
checkmate it I lose a bunch of pieces I
have a question box box on move 7 so why
didn't you take his night uh well boys
back a great question I was under the
impression that if I take his night
mm-hmm he must have had something genius
planned I did I go Bishop to c6 run it
on the simulation then he takes with his
pawn I take with my queen Oh your pin
soccer isn't pork yeah double forks have
two pins in them it's a two prompt in
yeah yeah this is this is a fork there
is a way that he can defend the rook and
the King but honestly it is a little bit
hard to see Bishop d7 he's blocking the
check and he's protecting the rook but
if you didn't see that you know the
simulation would have worked
oh yeah but he wouldn't have done that
well I did do that in the game wondering
the whole time man you would have done
there's no way no way okay yeah maybe
that makes sense actually yeah um but
you did bait him and it did end up
working and he car is there another
moment in the position where you had a
question right so one position was when
later when you had the Queen the bishop
line on the other other line towards the
king right here after the bishop moves
did you see that you could take the
bishop and then take the pawn after that
with your queen I thought about this
move for a while and I and I and I
thought I could take and then and then
for some reason I thought he could just
block with rook and then but I still am
a pawn up but for some reason I was like
I need more more more MORE wait I can
I'm sorry
yeah go ahead Albert I was gonna say uh
what about the pawn on d4 so it okay
first let's let's take a quick look at
it so if black was the King here there's
this knight move to f7 check forking the
Queen and the king and black has to give
the
rook for the night and so white is ahead
by a little bit here oh oh oh you did
have to go a little bit deep to see this
light and it is still tricky the pawn on
d4 is hanging so I can see why why box
foxes plan was to try to get it back but
this would have been really dangerous
for sure and just to go back then to the
opposition of Knight takes pawn with the
bishop on e6 Bishop Knight takes pawn
yeah yeah sorry
he really takes bishop Pancho's 19 spawn
inside yeah after taking on the bishop
here we go but here there's Bishop takes
pawn which is a check so black can't
capture the King Ludwig I'm scared to
argue with them I feel like these guys
know their stuff this one I think what
mean box box went for the blunder line
was a little more proactive in profile
reflect prophylactics so that's what we
were thinking but honestly not a bad you
know thought yeah we're just backseat
gaming here you know this is a little
bit rude sometimes but we appreciate you
guys being good sports like when I play
against my twitch ad they always
backseat game but you guys actually know
you're saying yeah I saw after the fact
but I didn't see it until he had moved
his knight and then and then I felt oh
god that was that that was brutal
this was brutal box box that last tactic
by you was a masterpiece did how far
behind did you see it alright oh like at
what point did you get this idea I was
like three moves in advance and then I
almost made it like three times while
running into something like that it was
like something in the way like three
times I'm like right about to instantly
lock in that what I thought was a check
man like oh wait the Bishop's there oh
wait
the Queen's there oh wait something else
and then on the third time there was
finally nothing in the way I was like
okay I can do it now
nice nice no that was beautiful and
Ludwig did this catch you by surprise at
all honestly Alex no you knew it's gonna
happen I feel like you actually lost a
box box on purpose because you have been
running multiple computer simulations to
see how you can optimize the amount of
prize
money you're gonna get and maybe going
for like the consolation bracket and
finishing first this is gonna be more
than we're having this is a weird
thought process I've never thought this
interesting interesting no I would Wow
you could have backed me up one time
never again never again
don't self-incriminating the one rule I
wanted to go out like that guy in in was
Forrest Gump I went to die in the
battlefield oh okay look I could have I
could have had him take off my limb one
part buy at a time but I thought let's
go out honorably I see this checkmate
what do you see it three head I saw it
for a head and I thought let's set him
up for it you know let's let's let them
let's let him see this one in he needs
this well he car anything you want to
add on that game there no I just saw it
actually out of all the matches in the
first round it was definitely one of the
most entertaining games and one of the
ones that really both of you guys use a
lot of time and it still was was wasn't
clear until just the very last last move
this nighty to chuck winning a game so I
thought you both played played a very
good game and it was just very
complicated a lot of rollercoasters but
you both had your chances yeah and and
this was the first game for both of you
in pogchamp how was it compared to your
expectations maybe box box you can start
I was really nervous I am happy I won
Thank You Shane talk to the mic like
you've never stream before in your life
oh yeah I was I was I was nervous I was
nervous but at the same time I was it
because cuz I know that he was I'm the
underdog and it's so much sicker to be
the underdog because you can just lose
and it doesn't matter and and and the
more he car gassed me out the less
nervous I was because I know that
everybody you've gassed up is lost so I
know secretly when you say that they
have like a 20-30 percent chance of
winning it means were well you all you
had to find was one good move man one
good move in time efore was good we can
admit this admittedly smart he's lucky
he's not a bo3 that's all I'm gonna say
Bo and unfortunately I'm so busy box box
so I can't even play right now cuz I'm
fortunate thing at 238 but if it was a
best-of-three who would have been over
curtains wow that that talk I mean he
Caro actually said that you kept
alternating between blunders and
fantastic moves so you you know you did
you did have some good moves in there
you just kind of even them out with
badness yeah and I think that's what we
call balance
yeah healthy balanced life well before
we let you guys go it would be awesome
to hear a bit more about your channels I
mean box box I know you've been
streaming for a long time we get a lot
of chests lately anything else you can
share with chat
yeah I signed up for this tournament for
one reason and one reason only as you
know I stream League of Legends and boy
boy on the other side of the bracket
ended my masters promos in league he was
on the other team and he ruined me so
this is mostly like a revenge story like
oh he's signing up for this tournament
sure I guess I can learn he's 1611 try
to catch up that's what this is all
about well that is the true
determination the storyline that
everybody has been waiting for and
Ludwig I know you do a ton of variety
anything you can share with the chat you
know what I just actually won a super
mario 64 World Championship last weekend
one of the best in the world at that but
I decided to take it to chess I'll be
honest I'm in it for the money
alright I'm gunning for the 10k that's
all I'm in it for I love it you guys
these answers are super refreshing box
box Ludwig thank you guys so much for
being here and best of luck with the
tournament in the future peace out guys
cool thank you so much all right on that
note we are taking a look at the
schedule so this oddity car this was so
much fun
yeah I mean I think this was probably
the the one of the two of two of my
favorite matchups in the first round the
other one being NIM and slicker but just
the general the response is the
wittiness in terms of what they were
saying there's just some classy answers
and that was just a lot of fun yeah I'm
with you there so I'm just gonna let you
guys know what the next matches are
because they're coming up tomorrow so we
are gonna have a Rob vs. Nate Hill and
this is gonna be super exciting because
Arab was talking some trash saying
there's no way I'm gonna lose to a
fortnight player Nate well Nate from
what I've seen he's super positive super
polite so I feel like he hasn't said
anything similar in return but you know
maybe he's gonna show it on the board
and I believe that we're also gonna have
voyboy versus foosley do you got any
prep for foosley so she can have another
mate in 13 yeah actually I'm gonna be
helping her a little bit later on stream
so once once I go live in like a nap
like in an hour hour and a half
we'll be trying to prepare and give her
some opening strategies strategies and
she will be playing with the black
pieces against some against boy boy
obviously boy boy is a big favor
but if Foose Lee can pull off an upset
upset she will guarantee herself a spot
in the champions bracket so gonna be
very interesting to see and that would
be the most incredible upsets as voyboy
is the favorite here we are also gonna
have hutch versus yeah so and what is
your take on that because hutch is
obviously the rating favorite but yeah
so has been improving so quickly yeah I
think that's actually gonna be a very
close match up as well both of them won
their first round matchups respectively
so I think I think yeah so who can get
out of the opening phase and sort of
spot some of these patterns and tactical
solutions he is a very good chance of
causing an upset
hutch certainly should be the favorite
but it's very dependent on on what what
happens in the first the opening part of
the game
absolutely well chat it has been a blast
this was the most watched stream on
Twitch and I would ask you to do
something but you would do the opposite
so please don't follow chess on Twitch
so that you miss all of these exciting
games go watch something else thank you
so much everyone for tuning in he car
you are awesome yeah you too
a lot of fun bye everyone bye